do you ever feel like you shouldn't have
gotten hit Oh got you [__] what the
[__] do you ever think no I definitely
hit him I bet I lost for words right now
do you ever unload an entire magazine on
a prone enemy and somehow miss every
goddamn shot well my friends if you
answered yes to any of these questions
you're probably just [__] what did you
say that or you've been shafted by a
hitbox hitboxes have been around since
pretty much the beginning of game design
and as long as whatever you're playing
has any sort of interaction your
character has hit boxes and hurt boxes
and when a hit box connects with a hurt
box
you're either dishing out lumps or
taking them but despite their name hit
boxes can also be circles or even a
human-shaped mesh that surrounds your
character all that really matters is
their ability to register contact with
other hit boxes and as a result they're
wonderfully easy to scapegoat one [__]
doesn't go your way
hitbox heat Bucks players only really
became aware of hitboxes in the early
90s when Street Fighter 2 popularized
fighting games during that time Japanese
strategy guides were released including
hitbox diagrams for characters inspiring
players to study them and use that
knowledge against their opponents and
today mastering hit and hurt boxes
remains as important as ever being able
to recognize openings and responding
with counters is an art form and
fighting game players are constantly
looking to hit their opponents extended
hurt box with their hip box biding his
time no meat a friendship what by smug
off of the slide it's known in the fgc
as the whiff punish and as easy as the
pros make it look it's one of the
hardest things for new players to learn
mostly because they're just mashing
buttons
but not all hitboxes are created equal
hitboxes and her boxes can be bad for
any number of reasons they can be too
big too small or completely non-existent
and as strange as it might sound
just because an animation whips when it
looks like it should make contact
doesn't necessarily mean that hitbox is
bad sometimes it just makes more sense
for a games balance that a character's
attacking range is shorter than it looks
however a real problem is when a hitbox
is way bigger than an animation suggests
in Super Smash Brothers Brawl snake was
infamous for having hit boxes that
extended way further than they ever
should allegedly it's because he was
significantly larger in development but
when they scaled him down everything but
his hitbox shrank shrinkage yes
significant shrinkage over the years
fighting games have become notorious for
ridiculous hit boxes like this one more
proof look no further than melee which
gave us Yoshi and his 3d graph or Street
Fighter Alpha 2 which gave Sakura
backwards-facing hit boxes on just about
everything and of course there's Def Jam
fight for New York the greatest fighting
game ever made partially because of
sticky fingers and his legendary ghost
punches just watch touch them at all no
that's what makes this man busted please
tell me I want to understand but
fighting games aren't the only genre
that has to deal with messy hit boxes
MOBAs like league of legends are plagued
with them - just look at Lux's ultimate
which has a massive hitbox compared to
its tiny animation
or better yet blitzcrank's jackass
rocket grab which riot has finally fixed
due to it previously having an almost
inescapable reach first-person shooters
are all too familiar with sketchy hit
boxes as well counter-strike has had
problems for years like in the 2009
version of 1.6 where any time a player
moved there was a chance that their
hitbox could completely miss alive even
more bizarrely and source a character's
head Fox would move in front of them to
compensate for lag which meant that you
could shoot where someone was going to
be and actually hit them these days CS
goes hitboxes face a lot less scrutiny
than their previous iterations
however Rainbow six siege is constantly
targeted by players for having allegedly
wonky hitboxes
Bradlee the Victorian now every siege
player quickly learns that ash can be
incredibly hard to hit what what is
wrong with ash in China she's even
nicknamed the five-speed monster with no
head because of how fast and evasive she
is a reasonable person would assume
she's just too quick or that may be lag
makes it tough sometimes but a real
Galaxie brain siege player knows the
truth
the demonic buck-toothed nightmare just
doesn't have a hitbox on her head
alright alright I might be getting
carried away by my own saltiness the
truth is that while headshotting ash is
like nailing jello to the wall her
non-existent hitbox is a myth it's just
a mean you guessed right
we made this one on them but as
infuriating as hitboxes can be the more
serious instances of bad ones can be
potentially game-breaking look at what
happened to Soul Calibur 6 when hit
boxes for custom characters effectively
ruined online play and the moral of the
story here is that rank is a total
cesspool of perverted non-tournament
sanctioned created [__] and more
recently with Apex legends gibraltars
massive hurt box that launched basically
made him useless if you are trying to
play seriously he was just a bigger
naturally thicker target and of course a
broken hitbox can totally unbalanced a
game just look at clouds busted ass up
air and smash for prizes here for I'm in
chios shield almost breaking oh my gosh
and that's unfortunate if you mess up
and your aerial combos yep on the cloud
he can up air you that up air comes out
so fast whether you're with punishing a
button masher
getting hit by an invisible laser
or clicking on someone's whack-a-mole
head hitboxes dictate what happens to
you in game there gaming's atomic
structure the invisible pieces that
click together and make things work
behind the scenes and often they're the
fine margins between popping off and
dropping off i'm mathie recently I had
my own hitbox is surgically extended
check this out hey Matt it never gets
old and of course there's Def Jam fight
for New York the greatest fighting game
ever made partially because of ghosts is
not Ghostface Killah damn it's sticky
fingers I'm a Ghostface Killah mane and
of course there's Def Jam fight for New
York the greatest fighting game ever
made because of ghosts I really I love
Ghostface Killah go home and cry to your
mama and why you at each other I'm
hungry